Je ne veux pas me lever,
je ne veux pas y aller.
Je suis censée être en cours
depuis huit heures ce matin.
Il n'y a pas de solution,
parce qu'il n'y a pas de problème à régler.
Et genre, t’es là,
tu pleures,
tu sais pas pourquoi.
Tu te dis : mais meuf,
mais qu’est-ce qui t’arrives, en fait ?
Voilà.
Je crois qu’il y aura que des vidéos
où je suis dans un mood de merde.
C’est vraiment pas stable, en fait.
Parce que là, j'ai arrêté de chialer
et je me casse,
je vais voir une pote.
Louma, je t'aime !
Je suis même pas sûre
si j’ai envie qu’on garde ces videos.
Salut, c'est Juliette !
Et elle, c'est Louma.
Sur les réseaux sociaux,
on parle de plus en plus de la dépression.
En France, on estime
que près d’une personne sur cinq
a souffert ou souffrira
d'une dépression au cours de sa vie
et Louma fait partie de ces personnes.
Mais elle n'est pas seule dans son combat.
J'ai lancé une messagerie pour avoir
vos retours par rapport à vos expériences
avec la dépression
et vous êtes très nombreux
à vous sentir comme elle.
Vos messages, ils sont
super poignants et touchants.
Mais il y en a qui sont super inquiétants
et du coup, j’y reviendrai en fin de vidéo
pour en parler un peu plus.
Pour comprendre ce qu'est vraiment
une dépression,
on va écouter Louma.
Je l'ai rencontrée il y a quelques mois,
via son compte TikTok.
Elle le tient avec une amie à elle.
En octobre dernier,
Louma s'est fait hospitaliser
une dixième fois
pour ses troubles psychiatriques.
Elle a 18 ans
et c'est là, en psychiatrie,
qu'elle a rencontré Vicky
et qu'elles ont décidé de lancer
un compte TikTok ensemble.
Parce qu’elles s'ennuyaient,
mais surtout
parce qu’elles voulaient
documenter leur maladie.
Vous m'avez demandé de vous faire une vidéo
sur la différence entre les idées noires
et les idées suicidaires.
En fait, ça fait longtemps
que je voulais parler de ce sujet.
Déjà, c’est quelque chose dont on parle beaucoup avec mes potes
et puis c'était le sujet le plus demandé
dans mes DM sur Instagram.
Du coup, je me suis dit : OK,
on parle souvent de la dépression,
mais sans savoir exactement
ce que ça entraîne.
Et beaucoup de gens qui en souffrent
se sentent souvent mis à part
et pas légitimes dans leur ressenti.
Du coup, pour qu'on comprenne le quotidien
d'une personne en dépression,
j'ai demandé à Louma de se filmer
et elle a accepté.
Enfin bref !
Voilà, c’est pas la forme, miss.
C'est quoi, la dépression ?
C'est un peu compliqué parce que ça varie
en fonction des personnes.
À mes yeux,
c'est une période où tu as un peu
l'impression de perdre toute ta vitalité.
C'est la première vidéo que je fais.
Sur le coup, je sais pas si je suis
super à l'aise avec l’idée.
Je ne suis capable de rien,
je ne peux pas ranger,
je ne peux pas manger,
je ne peux rien,
rien de ce qui est normal pour les gens,
se lever, aller se laver,
manger, ranger.
Je peux rien faire.
Tu n'as plus d'envie,
tu n'as plus rien qui te fait plaisir.
C’est beaucoup de fatigue
mentale et physique aussi.
Et en même temps,
tu te sens pas légitime de dire :
“Bah là, je sors, là, je suis heureuse,
je suis avec mes potes, je suis bien.”
Et même si, au fond,
c'est toujours compliqué dans ces moments-là,
on peut passer des bons moments.
J'ai rencontré, dans le train,
Capu, qui m'a filé un putain d’avocat
parce que j'avais la dalle
et au final, on s'est retrouvées avec...
- Laura.
- Laura, ouais.
Je lui ai dit :
”Viens boire un coup avec moi.”
- Voilà.
Donc là, on va boire un coup tous ensemble.
- On m'a déjà fait la remarque :
“Mais regarde, là tu es en train
de rigoler avec tes copains,
tu sors, tu es pas en dépression.”
Bah ouais, je rigole avec mes copains,
je sors, mais au fond, je suis pas bien.
Les gens se fient à ce qu'ils voient
et ils ne savent pas ce qu’il se passe
à l'intérieur.
Donc, c'est compliqué.
En cette fin de journée,
je n'ai rien fait.
Rien, absolument rien.
Je suis restée au lit.
J'ai végété toute la journée.
J'ai pas pris de douche.
J'ai pas mangé.
Je me suis pas habillée.
J’ai vraiment rien fait, en fait.
Louma est fille unique.
Petite, elle est curieuse et super active.
Elle fait plein de sports comme du tennis,
des sports de combat, etc.
À huit ans, elle quitte sa maison pour partir
en internat à deux heures de chez elle.
Et à 11 ans,
son papa quitte la France.
Et même s'ils se parlent
encore un peu aujourd'hui,
son absence l'a beaucoup marquée à l'époque.
À douze ans,
elle se fait virer de son collège
pour des problèmes de comportement.
Et dans son nouvel internat,
où elle ne connaît personne,
elle commence à se scarifier les bras.
À partir de ce moment-là,
j'ai vu une psychologue
qui m'a tout de suite dit :
”Au vu de ce que vous me racontez
et des actes que vous avez envers vous,
ce serait peut-être bien
qu’on vous hospitalise.”
Et à partir de ce moment-là,
ça a été très, très long,
parce qu‘à 12 ans,
on ne peut pas dire à quelqu'un
“vous avez  telle ou telle maladie”.
Mais le problème, c'est qu'un diagnostic,
ça peut prendre jusqu'à 10 ans
à partir du moment où tu es majeur.
Louma, elle a 14 ans
et c’est 2 ans après sa première scarification.
Elle passe tout l'été 2018
dans un hôpital psychiatrique.
Mais en vrai,
ça lui fait pas beaucoup de bien
parce que les docteurs lui disent
que c'est une crise d'ado,
alors que Louma, elle sait
qu'elle se sent super mal.
Et 2 ans plus tard,
elle fait sa première TS,
c'est-à-dire tentative de suicide.
Pour les gens, c'est juste : la flemme,
je reste au lit et je pleure.
C'est la crise d'ado, c'est normal,
tu te cherches,
tu sais pas vraiment qui tu es,
donc c'est normal que tu sois un peu triste.
Et quand tu essaies d'expliquer
à ces gens-là que,
ouais enfin, ça dure depuis que j’ai 11-12 ans,
je vais en avoir 19,
au bout d’un moment, je pense
que c'est beaucoup plus profond,
et les gens te disent :
“Non, non, mais c'est dans ta tête,
fais un effort,
va faire un peu de sport et puis ça ira mieux.”
Depuis sa première hospitalisation à 14 ans,
Louma a été hospitalisée 10 fois
pour des séjours de 2 semaines à 3 mois.
À cause de toutes ces absences,
elle a redoublé sa seconde et sa première.
Niveau vie amicale, c'est difficile.
Beaucoup de ses potes la lâchent
parce que c’est dur à gérer,
ses changements d'humeur
et ses annulations à la dernière minute.
Je viens de me réveiller
et j'ai prévu de partir avec une pote.
On doit prendre le train dans une heure.
Et comme d'hab,
jusqu'à la dernière minute,
j'étais trop hypée.
Et là, j'ai qu'une envie, en fait,
c'est de me tirer une balle.
C'est chiant de...
Je vais faire des trucs trop bien
et puis mon corps et mon cerveau,
ils me disent genre :
“Bah non.”
Sa vie amoureuse est compliquée aussi.
Elle a une copine
pendant un peu plus d'un an,
mais ça finit par se terminer,
parce que c'est pas simple
d'être avec quelqu'un qui est en dépression.
Inconsciemment,
dans les moments où tu es pas bien,
tu fais énormément
souffrir les gens autour de toi
par le fait que tu t’isoles,
tu parles pas, les gens voient que tu vas mal
et ils se sentent impuissants.
On va te proposer quelque chose,
tu vas dire oui
et à la dernière minute tu vas dire :
”Absolument pas, en fait,
là je le sens pas.”
Et les gens ne comprennent pas,
et les gens te disent...
te font culpabiliser
sans le vouloir en te disant :
”Bah ouais, mais regarde, c’est pas cool,
tu m’as dit que tu venais,
au final, tu viens pas.”
Quand j'étais à Bordeaux,
j'ai rencontré une de ses copines,
Lupita,
qui est restée amie avec elle.
Elles se sont rencontrées
dans un lycée alternatif
qui essaie d'accompagner
des élèves en difficulté.
- Tu es déjà partie
pendant des longues périodes de temps ?
- Le max : 3 mois.
Vu qu'on évolue tous un peu ensemble,
il y a ce truc, de grandir, comme une famille.
Je sais que ça peut aussi
être compliqué quand tu arrives
et que tu sais pas ce qui s'est passé.
Tout le monde a passé 3 mois ensemble,
a évolué ensemble,
a vécu des choses ensemble.
Moi, j'arrive au bout de 3 mois,
je ne sais pas ce qui s'est passé.
Je ne comprends pas tout
et là, on te regarde et on te dit :
”Bah ouais, mais en même temps,
tu étais pas là pendant 3 mois,
donc on va pas s'arrêter
de vivre pour toi, tu vois.”
J'essaie de la motiver,
d'être là pour elle, le plus que je peux,
et qu'elle soit heureuse.
Même si c’est pas facile
tous les jours, mais bon...
Je sais que je ne la laisserai pas,
comme d'autres personnes ont pu le faire,
parce que je sais ce que ça fait
et que j'ai pas envie
qu'elle vive la même chose
parce que je suis attachée à elle,
donc je veux juste qu'elle aille mieux
et bien.
En fait, vu que Louma ne parle pas
souvent de ses problèmes
et communique peu,
ça rend les choses difficiles
pour sa famille.
Louma en est consciente.
Elle ne leur donne pas les moyens de l'aider
et du coup, eux, ils ne savent pas quoi faire.
J'ai eu des moments
où même les gens de ma famille
au bout d’un moment me disaient...
C’est horrible...
Ils faisaient des comparaisons,
ils me disaient :
”Regarde les gens qui vivent la guerre,
ils ont pas le temps d'être en dépression,
ils ont pas le temps d'être soignés.”
Tu te sens hyper seule quand
même ta famille comprend plus,
que tes amis, ils te disent :
”Ouais, mais là, fais un effort.”
Et même des fois, mon psychiatre m'a dit :
”Je peux rien faire pour toi,
je peux absolument rien faire pour toi.”
Donc, là tu te dis :
je suis toute seule,
toute seule.
C'est pas super, super fun.
Je profite d'avoir
un élan de lucidité, on va dire.
Je vais me préparer, je vais sortir
pour essayer de stimuler mon cerveau.
Aujourd'hui, son traitement,
c’est 10 médicaments par jour,
dont des anxiolytiques,
des régulateurs d'humeur et des somnifères.
Une infirmière vient
chez elle tous les jours pour lui déposer
le nombre exact de médicaments car elle n'a pas le droit d'avoir des pilules chez elle,
par précaution.
Louma a encore beaucoup de chemin
à faire avant de se sentir mieux.
Elle n'est pas sûre qu'elle pourra
passer le bac cette année
et ça voudrait dire qu'elle doit
redoubler une troisième fois.
J'aurais bien voulu plus vous montrer
ses amis et ses moments positifs,
mais en ce moment,
elle est assez seule
et pas très motivée pour sortir.
Évidemment, cet état,
ça n'aide pas à vivre la même vie
que les autres jeunes de 18 ans.
Mais Louma, elle garde l'espoir que les choses
vont s'améliorer pour elle.
Ça fait 5 ans que je suis suivie.
J'ai l'impression de ne pas avancer
et au fond de moi,
j'ai la rage, genre, je veux avancer,
je veux m'en sortir
et j'ai l'impression d'être bloquée.
Le seul obstacle dans tout ça,
c'est moi-même.
J'aimerais bien travailler en psychiatrie,
parce que le fait d'y passer
énormément de temps,
ça m'a donné envie d'aider les autres
et de leur montrer que c'est possible.
Accroche-toi,
ça va être dur, accroche-toi,
mais ça va aller.
Pour terminer cette vidéo,
je voulais parler des messages
les plus inquiétants que j'ai reçus
sur la messagerie de Brut.
En fait, il y en a beaucoup
que j'ai trouvé très troublants
parce qu'il y avait énormément
de messages avec des intentions suicidaires.
Évidemment,
je ne vais pas vous les faire écouter.
Mais comme tous ces messages
sont anonymes,
je n'ai pas pu mettre en contact
leurs auteurs avec des gens
qui pourraient les aider.
Moi, je suis pas psy,
ni médecin, évidemment,
mais si j'ai un conseil,
c'est de ne pas rester seul
et en parler autour de vous.
Et si jamais vous n'avez pas envie
d'en parler avec vos proches,
il y a un numéro gratuit
et anonyme que vous pouvez appeler
pour recevoir du soutien.
C'est le 31 14.
Prenez soin de vous,
on se voit bientôt pour la prochaine vidéo.
Et comme toujours,
n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer un message
sur Instagram pour d'autres idées de sujet.
Même si je ne peux pas répondre
à tout le monde,
je les lis tous et je les vois.
Et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que j'ai réalisé cette vidéo.
Si vous avez trouvé
cette vidéo intéressante,
vous pouvez vous abonner
à notre chaîne YouTube.
À la prochaine !